next time you rent a car it could
actually drive up to your location on
its own yeah it's a new electric option
that one company is about to launch here
in las vegas christian casada shows us
how it will work
we want to work with friendly
policymakers that are progressive minded
it's called halo car and it can soon be
driving on its own to your location it's
a unique product where our customers
take your app push a button request a
car
we will remotely drive an all-electric
driverless car to the doorstep
once it gets there you as a customer
jump into the driver's seat drive it
wherever you want to go the company's
founder anat nanda kumar inviting me to
take a ride to check out how the state
of the art technology works people
compare us to autonomous cars all the
time we're drastically different in fact
i call this a contrarian approach the
car does all the navigation itself or
the signaling all of it itself during
our ride we cruised around downtown las
vegas crossing intersections to see how
the vehicle moves until it arrives to
the customer autonomous cars are not
there right now in the world it's fully
deployed it's because edge cases what do
you do in a construction zone you just
talked about what do you do when there's
a random bed in the middle road what do
you do when there's a park car truck in
the middle of the road how do you handle
those kind of situations electric square
right looks clear
turning left off inside the company's
headquarters off the strip we got a look
at the human operator controlling the
rental car via the 5g network with six
monitors to get a full view do you think
las vegas is ready for this i absolutely
think las vegas is ready for this
and
people here want better product better
services christian casa is live local
now